hi welcome to this week's episode of
cold fusion
last week we looked at neural link but
this week we're going to look at
something completely different
in the 1880s the automobile was the
latest achievement in transport
and two decades later the wright
brothers took humanity to the skies with
the first
successful aircraft for over a century
the question has been asked could we
successfully merge the two technologies
the first serious attempt was made in
1917 by the aviator
glenn curtis his autoplane was powered
by a rear-mounted four-blade propeller
it did leave the ground but it couldn't
achieve full flight
the next notable design was the aerocar
by the inventor
malt taylor it successfully flew in 1949
but only six were ever built over the
decades
many have tried to crack the code of the
flying car but no one has succeeded yet
recently a team out of japan showed
their latest efforts to achieve this
dream
but will they succeed in this video
we'll take a look at this
but then we'll ask deeper questions and
branch out into the wider electric
aircraft market
we're going to uncover some problems and
solutions
let's get into it you are watching
cold fusion tv
last month japan showcased a flying car
built by the company skydrive
who was sponsored by toyota
the vehicle is powered by eight
independent electric motors and has been
in development since 2014
though it was only publicly demonstrated
for the first time last month
i know what some of you are thinking
that's not a flying car
that's just a passenger drone well this
is just the test phase
the next step will be to add wheels a
spokesperson for skydrive explains
quote before developing a prototype with
wheels
we would like to ensure that the
incredibly difficult flight function has
been achieved as a first step
we aim at driving function from late
2020
in other words concentrate on the hard
part first
getting the thing to fly then stick the
wheels on it later
a trivial task in comparison they
continue
quote we believe that we can add more
value in places like japan and asia
where the land is small
and it is difficult to land and take off
from
they aim to go for commercial manned
flights in 2023
the final product will cost around
thousand us dollars
they hope to decrease the cost by 2030
skydrive's unique selling point is that
this product is one of the most compact
and light flying car designs out there
there are several companies developing
similar technology including airbus
as well as toyota porsche is teaming up
with boeing
and in january hyundai and uber
announced that they were collaborating
on an
all-electric air taxi for me personally
after i took a flight in one of the
first all-electric aircraft
the alpha electro i could see that maybe
small electric aircraft could be a thing
in one form or another morgan stanley
analysts state
that they expect urban air taxis to be
common by 2040 with a global market
expected to be about 1.5 trillion
dollars
so why are electric aircraft becoming a
thing
in short less emissions cheaper running
costs
and simpler maintenance let's take a
closer look at these points
electric aviation has the promise of
greatly reducing financial and
environmental costs of existing air
transport
according to the australian airport
association the biggest airline costs
are fuel and maintenance
fuel makes up about 27 and maintenance
11
the running costs are powering electric
aircraft is low and they are
intrinsically less complex than their
fuel counterparts too
fewer moving parts and a simpler design
mean less need for maintenance
[Music]
electric aircraft could also improve the
efficiency of local airports
and allow airports in more diverse
locations
today a lot of airports often have to
comply with pollution regulations
this causes a curfew for when aircraft
can take off and land
the result is possible congestion
throughout the rest of the operational
period
with electric aircraft airports are
freed from these restrictions
improving efficiency reducing costs and
with the added benefit
of being allowed to be placed nearer to
city centres
this even opens up opportunities for new
kinds of work arrangement
though this has become less relevant
recently with more people working from
home these days
in the broader picture it's not all
roses for the emerging industry
let's take a look at some problems
firstly batteries the key issue
affecting the uptake of electric
aircraft
is the need to ensure enough battery
energy density to support commercial
flights
as mentioned previously many times in
this channel the ball is rolling
graphene solid state and aluminium air
are recent developments that are looking
likely in the next few years
by 2022 nine seat planes could be doing
short-haul flights
about 500 to a thousand kilometers for
example
the israeli firm aviation has built a
nine-passenger aircraft that is rated to
fly up to a thousand kilometers
at an altitude of 3000 meters and a
speed of 440 kilometers an hour
it's expected to enter service in 2022
the key here was to use aluminium air
batteries instead of the less practical
lithium ion batteries
aluminium air batteries have a specific
energy of about 1
300 watt hours per kilogram versus
lithium ion at about 260 watt hours per
kilogram
looking at this medium-sized fixed-wing
aircraft
may be where most of the action is to
begin with
smaller electric vertical takeoff and
landing aircraft or e-vetol may be ruled
as less efficient when this industry
starts taking off
as ella atkins a professor of aerospace
engineering at the university of
michigan states
evitol aircraft quote are going to be
more energy efficient than helicopters
that use a lot of fuel
but they will be less efficient than
cars because they have to lift
themselves
from a cost perspective they wouldn't be
practical to go to the grocery store
so even when the battery issue is solved
there's still one thing holding back the
future of this industry
and it's something that no one's really
talking about and it doesn't really seem
that many people are thinking about this
either
that is the conundrum of the charging
standards
imagine for a second if every car
maker's fuel pump was different
how inconvenient and inefficient would
the automotive industry be
that's essentially what's happening for
electric cars no one really planned for
the charging aspect of the industry
the charges provided by different
manufacturers don't agree with each
other and
even the same manufacturer can have
different charges for different regions
it's a mess and here's exactly what i
mean
the chademo charging standard from japan
is the oldest
it was originally developed by nissan
for their leaf car but it's now
redundant in favor of newer standards
[Music]
tesla in the united states uses a
different standard
it's simple and compact but proprietary
and has limited voltage capacity
tesla has another charger for europe and
australia but they also have yet another
charger for china and india
a separate chinese standard called gb t
is the newest
dc fast charging standard despite being
only a few years old
it has surpassed the uptake of all other
charging standards by a factor of 10
and looks like the way forward
so what is the solution to avoid this
mess for the future electric aircraft
industry
aviation can benefit from all of these
lessons learnt in the electric car
market
and the mess of charging standards it
can also
capitalize on the progress made with the
promising chinese standard
i had a chat to a team who was working
on just this
at the start of 2018 electro aero was
the first to obtain approval from an
aviation regulator
to commercially operate an electric
light sport aircraft for recreational
flight training
since then they identified the need for
standardized aviation charging to help
accelerate the uptake of electric
aircraft
electro aero was the company that i
worked with when testing the alpha
electro aircraft in a previous video
the failed attempt at a challenge
associated with a cross-country trip was
largely due to the proprietary charger
and a generator
cto and co-founder of electro aero josh
portlog
helped establish and run an
international committee for developing
electric aircraft charging standards in
mid-2018
josh and his team at electro aero are
close to finalizing a universal charging
standard for aircraft that will be known
as
as6968 the electric aviation industry
has shown their support in the form of
many electric aircraft companies around
the world
the company recently made a test flight
of australia's first microlight aircraft
that employs this new as6968 charging
standard
the company also has a 30 kilowatt rapid
charger to top up batteries in less than
an hour
and they're already on sale if you're
interested in seeing the first test
flight along with some other info on
their rapid charger and the new standard
being developed
i'll leave a link in the description
below
the physical protocol of the charger is
based on the chinese standard
this saves the aviation industry a lot
of money because they don't have to
reinvent the wheel
the software protocol also has ties to
the existing standard
though there are additional features and
considerations specifically designed for
the aviation industry
for example the new electro aero
charging standard can
handle redundant batteries on board an
aircraft
this is common in aviation but rare in
electric cars
in the future the team also plans to use
automated
cloud-based billing complete with
aircraft identification
this is so each charger automatically
knows exactly what plane is being
charged
and how much the subsequent energy cost
will be
no apps no account logins or any other
hassles that current electric vehicle
sector has to deal with
while the charging standard is designed
to cater up to 250 kilowatts
or about a one to four seater plane
there is eventually going to be a need
for megawatt power levels
but that's for the future right now it
is good that this problem is being
looked at
and once standardized charging is
developed and adopted it will bring us
one step closer to an
airborne electric air taxi feature
why did it fail in the past the reasons
are
power plant was too heavy power plant
was too noisy
electric motors were not uh prolific and
low weight at this
this time in development carbon fiber
structures didn't exist these vehicles
were trying to be all things they were
trying to be a good car
and a good aircraft and unfortunately
they compromised on both of those design
challenges so why will it succeed in the
future well things have changed
yep we now have high power density
batteries we have low
mass electric motors we have low noise
fans we have lightweight carbon
composite
structures and now across the world 120
of these concert vehicles exist
and they're increasing at a rate of
about one a week at present
so that's about it from me though i'm
curious to know your thoughts on the
electric aircraft industry
do you think that we're a mere five
years away from seeing flying cars
become a reality
or do you think that this is all going
to take much longer
let me know your thoughts in the
comments section below
in next week's episode we'll be taking a
look at some cool uses for artificial
intelligence
and i'll be having an interview with a
developer who's doing some cool stuff
anyways my name is digo and you've been
watching cold fusion
and if you do want to see more stuff on
science technology business or history
definitely subscribe to cold fusion
there's a lot of stuff that you'll find
interesting
okay so i'll see you again next week for
the next episode
cheers guys
it's me thinking
you